yesterday was the LA Marathon it was a
big deal yeah yeah yeah yeah people who
ran it said it was nice to finally get
from downtown Los Angeles to Santa
Monica in less than four hours
thanks for the nipple robbed by the way
sir God then a beer yeah very nice we
just in had an interesting technique he
was toggling it like a switch
weird guy vladimir putin has been
reelected to a fourth term as president
of russia yeah yeah yeah the final vote
tally was 76% for Putin 24% shot this
morning
why are you applauding people getting
shot that is how the system works yeah
yeah right
in a new survey 73 percent of teachers
are opposed to being trained to carry a
gun yeah the the other 27% our art
teachers who finally want some goddamn
respect in Indiana police found a man at
a White Castle with a container of
dangerous chemicals yeah the man had a
White Castle with dangerous chemicals is
known as the cook
language teaching app duolingo you
familiar with that okay settle down it's
just an app language teaching app do
lingo recently added Klingon - its
course selection they added Klingon yeah
by the way if you have the dual lingo
app on your phone and you use it to
learn Klingon you can delete tinder
because
[Applause]
you